hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from round nine of
the second day of the world rapid
championship it's boris girlfriend
versus not rebecca du sotorov uh it's
quite a game let's check it out and then
we're gonna discuss on what happens next
so boris with the white pieces opens
with d4 uh we have knight to f6 by abdul
satoru knight to f3 d5 and now c4 we
have e6 so queen's gambit declined is on
the board and now g3 boris opts for the
catalan opening d captures on c4 and now
bishop to g2
we have knights the c6 and queen to a
for now pinning this knight and bishop
to b for check this is the absolute main
line uh and both of them are uh very
familiar with it as it would seem so
knight bishop d2 blocking check and now
knight to d5 defending the bishop as
it's attacked twice so bishop captures
on b for knight captures and now knight
to c3 and this is a well-known position
uh where usually player players just
continue bishop to d7 so you can move
this knight and the the game goes on but
here we have rook to b8 it's a very
sneaky idea uh by uh young notre back
here and it is now as of move nine that
we have a completely new game uh so
let's see uh what what the plan is
obviously you want to execute b5 at some
point but how will that happen so here
we have a3 boris chases away the knight
knight to d5 and now queen captures on c
for for the moment b5 is impossible
because the knight would hang so here
what is just uh another big just castles
we have rook to d1
uh and now comes knight the a5 attacking
the queen here queen to d3 and only now
we have b5 and now
you are preparing to bring this knight
to c4 but what about the b5 pawn can the
b5 pawn be captured well the problem is
if you capture this of course bishop to
a6 is incredibly unpleasant and even if
you play a four to stop uh to
prevent the loss of a piece c6
and that's it white can resign so of
course uh white cannot capture this pawn
uh we have castles by girlfriend and not
knight to c4 going for that b2 pawn so
griffin has to retreat with the queen
queen to c2 and now knight captures and
see three queen captures on c3 he
doesn't want to play b captures then the
a3 pawn becomes weak so queen captures
and now bishop to b7 ready to counter
boris is a strong light square bishop on
g2 we have knight to d2 offering to
trade off everything and here comes the
bishop captures on g2 king captures and
a wonderful centralizing move
with queen to d5 with check king to g1
and now rook f2d8 putting pressure on
the d4 pawn so this prevents white from
executing e4 right away so knight
captures on c4 we have b counters and c
for for the moment doubling black spawns
but uh it's not a problem boris plays
rook to d2 prepares to bring the rook to
d1 also adds additional support to the
b2 pawn but now rook to b3 and you can
see how all of black's play is pretty
much based on this uh rook to b8
followed by b5 idea the pawn is now
nicely placed on c4 and the rook has a
beautiful outpost on b3 so queen back to
c2 and now another wonderful move c3
completely undermining white's position
getting rid of your doubled pawn but
this will make this pawn weak this one
weak and well black will just collect
the pawn so b captures on c3 and now
queen to c4 attacking this pawn and you
can also capture this pawn so queen d3
and now queen captures on c3 we have
rook f to d1 and here rook captures an
a3 and after all is said and done uh
nodribeck is up upon
so here we have uh queen captures on c3
rook captures on c3 and now boris goes
after the a7 pawn with rook to a1 uh so
black is up upon but it's a rook end
game both pairs of rooks are on the
board so it's not going to be easy to
convert this pawn uh instead of this
also d5 is is an idea but i guess boris
still wants to keep some chances alive
uh c5 of course the pawn is captured you
cannot move it otherwise the rook falls
here so rook captures an a7 and now uh
you could go after this pawn with c
captures on d4 but um uh well for
example c captures and the four row
captures you can't capture with the rook
because of the back rank checkmate so
abdusa satoro first makes some breeding
room for the king g6 is played and now
we have rook to c7 attacking
putting pressure on the pawn but just
rook captures uh on d4 yeah and now if
you capture it's possible to capture but
then pawn captures and the black has no
problems here so boris goes back rook to
a2 and now we have rook to d5 adding
more support to the pawn
and now you can move the the c3 rook so
rook the a8 check king to g7 and now
what can white play here well there are
a lot of moves white can play that uh
lead to a draw for example just rook to
a7 going after the f7 pawn is is enough
for white to
claim a draw other moves are possible as
well for example rook to a6 threatening
rook captures on e6 so many moves here
but boris plays pretty much the only
move that loses the game he plays pawn
to e4 attacks the rook and even though
it looks like you shouldn't be losing
the game
that's exactly what you've done so feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for abdusa toro while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not going rook to
d1 check even though you know it's
always uh hard to resist giving a check
i know so for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations uh you are an
excellent uh avoider of useless checks
rook to d2 is the move
and now there is no defense against rook
to c2 and the just gobbling up all of
the pawns and well endor checkmating the
white king boris tries rook to a1 he
wants to play rook to f1 to defend his
f2 pawn but it doesn't matter rook to c2
goes after the pawn we have to defend it
rook to f1 and now just rook to e2 and
he was in this position on the move 34
that boris girlfriend resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
you're already down upon and now you're
losing this spawn and then you'll be
down two pawns and being down two pawns
means a completely winning endgame for
black
problem is you cannot play f3 because
you're getting checkmated rook g2
checking each one rook captures king g1
and now the other rook delivers
checkmate so that's why you cannot
defend
the pawn
uh unfortunately for gilfand
so after this
unfortunate rook to e2 he resigned and
that's a third win in a row for uh for
young abu abdul satorov which means uh
he is now on seven points he is sharing
second place with uh uh grishok and nepo
and he will be facing none other than
magnus cross and in the next round here
uh you can see now how his tournament
went so far so first a victory against
uh mikhailevskiy then a victory against
dude then a victory against caruana then
through two draws one against nepal one
against alexander grishock
then a loss to anton korobov the always
unpleasant horrible uh you know just
grabbing as many sculpts as he can then
a win against arunian then a win against
watashik and then a win against the
boris girlfriend so he's having an
amazing tournament but it's uh magnus
who he will be facing next he has the
white pieces against magnus so we'll see
uh we'll see how he how he does uh this
will not be their first encounter if you
remember they also had a very very
interesting game in the 2019 world blitz
championship i made a video on that game
it was completely crazy i think uh of
the satoru was winning at some point but
if you guys have some extra time and
want to check it out it's it's a very
short video uh it will be the first
thing you see in the description below
so also enjoy that maybe as a
preparation is probably unless it's a
complete snooze fest we will be covering
abdul satoro versus magnus in the next
video
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank czech
made epilepsy catherine malta uh jack
schroeder uh jeffrey radenor and david
kimura for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
magnificent event
until it ends thank you i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day